[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the eye economist ian dunt and the
spectators economics correspondent kate
andrews there they both are standing by
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the telegraph pictures a jubilant
emmanuel macron who tonight became the
first french president for 20 years to
secure re-election
that's also the lead for the ft which
says projections by polling agencies
show that mr macron has defeated his
far-right rival marine le pen
the guardian reports that he has
promised to unite the country after his
victory
and those election results are also the
lead story for the times
the eye hears that if the conservatives
perform poorly in the local elections
rebel backbenchers are poised to stage a
leadership challenge against boris
johnson
the metro tells the story of a
three-month-old kira glowden who along
with her mother and grandmother was
killed by a russian airstrike in ukraine
the paper calls her putin's tiniest
victim
the male has word of a shortage of
hormone replacement therapy drugs which
experts have said could lead to a mental
health crisis amongst women who take
them
and the star says men are complaining
that they're being kept awake at night
by women who snore as loudly as vacuum
cleaners
and a reminder that uh by scanning the
qr code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
now we're joined tonight by ian dunt and
kate andrews i'm sure i'm in fact i'm
certain snoring isn't the preserve of
women only but anyway we'll move on uh
from that story let's talk about the
french
elections and uh with at the moment i
think it's 58.5
um of the vote gathered by the exit poll
macron is way ahead ian
yeah he's way ahead i mean we're pretty
much done here there may be some changes
in degrees but we're not uncertain of
the results and the pain isn't uncertain
the result and macron certainly isn't
uncertain of the vote so we know which
way this has gone
it's impossible not to breathe a certain
side of relief right i mean what we were
facing in this election
was on a historic scale
it was described in various places as
sort of france's brexit i mean
essentially that's what le pen
represented it was much more serious
than brexit both in the sense that she
is more pernicious than brexit as a
project she's much further to the right
she is a really quite putrid politician
but also that if you had a le pen
victory she'd given up on sort of
formally saying that france should leave
the eu but what she would have done was
sabotage the eu from within and france
unlike the uk
is one of the twin engines of the eu
alongside germany if she had won you
would have been looking at an
existential threat to the european union
by a pro-putin
leader
during the war with ukraine so to say
we've dodged a bullet is to massively
understate what's happened here
there are concerns now but i think it's
okay for us to breathe a sigh of relief
about what we've seen here tonight
still though 41.5 percent of the vote um
predicted as of now
that still is a substantial number of
people who voted for le pen
we've heard from
president macron saying that you know
he's now wanting to unify the country
but that's an awful lot of people who
didn't want him as president what does
he do about that
kate
well i think that the big story out of
tonight's election isn't necessarily
that macron won because
whilst the polls leading up to election
day did suggest that perhaps he was only
ahead by a few percentage points
there was i think a sense of drama that
was built up around this election um
even possibly by macron's team because
if you are clearly the front runner you
still want to encourage people to turn
up the issue now is that a lot of people
didn't turn up um you know we're not
gonna know the exact figures but they
estimate currently that the abstention
rate may be the highest in 50 years and
i think this is where macron's going to
have a problem going into the national
assembly votes in a few weeks time i
think in early june um is that he may
not be able to keep his majority which
means that from a domestic perspective
it's going to be much harder in the next
five years that he has in office to get
things done but look it's a very
comfortable win for macron as i said
there were polls suggesting that this
could be very close and it's not close
um the french elections in the first
round enable somebody significantly more
radical to get through but in the second
round they make it much much harder for
them to win so once again someone
unsurprisingly the center has come
together and decided that they don't
want to choose that more radical option
for i'm sure many of the reasons that
ann just laid out but hopefully it's a
bit of a wake-up call for macron who
lead going into the first round in
particular wasn't really engaging with
voters didn't feel he had to show up in
the same way the cost of living crisis
has enabled marie le pen to increase her
vote share from 2017 until now is
something politicians across western
countries are having to deal with but
macron has certainly seemed to be
generous more aloof perhaps than certain
other politicians so a slight wake-up
call for him that may become even
stronger in the weeks to come when those
national assembly votes do come around
yes and uh according to the guardian le
pen succeeded in giving the far-right
its biggest ever score in a french
presidential election uh and after they
campaigned on the cost of living crisis
and promising a ban on the muslim
headscarf in public places now what what
does macron have to do now to to fulfill
his pledge to unite
the country he was saying in his speech
there at the um
the eiffel tower that he was a president
for the whole of france including those
who voted for marine le pen ian
i think what he means by that if we're
being honest about it is that he's going
to attack the center left and he runs as
a centrist predominantly economically i
think he can be fairly described as as
as a center right to the president he's
going to attack to the center left on
the basis that those were the votes that
were predominantly lent to him now it
was not clear all the way through that
that would actually take place you look
at melancholy melanoma
left-wing candidate in the first round
said i don't think you should vote to
look for le pen to his supporters he
couldn't quite bring himself to say you
should vote for macron and in fact when
you look at the polling around
minnesotan voters a really quite
substantial um chunk of them around 50
mark saying well they just couldn't end
their vote to anyone at all
that's a really
a really dangerous scenario to be in
that is that what looked like a fracture
of the anti-fascist force in society
where conservatives liberals centrists
socialists always agree with as a threat
from the far right you fight it it looks
today and we need more data it looks
today like that did not take place that
actually there was a center-left swing
macron is thinking in those terms it
would suggest that
quite differently to what he's saying
right now about united in the country
speaking for the whole of france what it
really means is i hear what you just
said i see the votes i got lent there
will be something of a left-wing
movement in the second term
would you agree with that kate
look i think it's absolutely possible
that when it comes to the cost of living
crisis he's going to give some more
handouts and and and giveaways to help
hopefully the those
who are struggling most on the lower end
of the pay spectrum again i don't think
that's especially unique to france this
is something that all western
politicians are having to deal with at
the moment and we should expect
throughout the summer come the autumn
that there are going to be more support
packages because the demand is growing
higher and higher but the problem is
that macron doesn't have a lot of time
to change tact in the weeks leading up
to this national assembly vote so i mean
i think the the major sigh of relief is
going to actually come from other
countries around the world who if they
were now having to negotiate with a le
pen who was posing with vladimir putin
just years ago and had to pull him off
of her campaign literature only recently
could be dealing with a completely
different and far more difficult far
less unified front in the west when it
comes to dealing with what's happening
uh in terms of russia's uh war against
ukraine at the moment
keeping macron in place as much as some
western leaders including boris johnson
sometimes struggle to get along with him
will be a sigh of relief on that
international front but domestically i
think france is in a bit of a muddle
right now and as ian pointed out it's
not just the rise of the far right you
also have the rise of the socialist left
you have the rise of voices that are
frustrated with the decisions and the
lack of engagement that macron has been
giving over the past five years and
indeed uh as ann also pointed out they
they did not think that le pen was the
solution to that they didn't think that
she was uh the the the what they should
actually go with in the end but that
doesn't mean that they're not going to
still want to put forward some kind of
protest vote so i think domestically
things are going to get harder for
macron even if internationally things
are going to remain roughly the same we
shall see kate and ian for the moment
thank you
coming up
from one politician whose future is
secure
to another whose future might not be
we'll look at a room and plot to oust
boris johnson when we come back
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me in dunt and kate
andrews there they are um let's have a
look at the eye your paper uh ian but
we'll get kate to to comment but first
of all um this is a story that i feel
like i've seen a hundred times before
plot to oust
the prime minister this is the very
latest conservative rebels plotting to
coordinate action to alice boris johnson
kate
well you have seen a hun a hundred times
before and actually as the eye front
points out and it's been felt that
there's been a discoordinated attempt
over the fifteen months from different
groups of conservative mps at different
moments when they've been frustrated
with the prime minister to take action
and that hasn't worked out so the is
reporting that more groups say the one
nation tory group the 2019 intake
including the red wall mps are
communicating now so that after the may
elections depending on what happens in
the local elections depending on what
happens with more party gate fines they
may work together to oust the pm we have
to take all of this with a big grain of
salt not least because i think it's
become increasingly difficult to see who
obviously replaces the prime minister if
he were to go um you know he has been in
very hot water for months on end now
when it comes to the party gate
accusations against him and if he gets
fines every other day in the coming
months that's going to be hard to
maintain but at the same time
the tories in particular are going to be
loath to replace a prime minister if
they're not sure who comes next and i
don't think there's agreement
especially since the obvious front
runners including people like rishi
sunak have had a very difficult time in
the press recently as well
ian do you think this is slightly
different in that we're we're hearing
now about coordinated action that that
forces are being joined up together to
actually get rid of the prime minister
yeah the coordination is interesting um
it's the tactical element that matters
right now and there's a certain kind of
ideological dimension to this right so
you're looking sort of more one nation
tories
with the sort of more right-wing brexity
2019 i mean but the thing is that used
to matter a lot more than it does now
because the tory party isn't actually a
very broad church anymore it stopped
being a broad church when boris johnson
purged any sort of moderate one-nation
tories during the brexit emergency or
the brexit wars and by the time you have
the 2019 elections the people that are
in the parliamentary party are committed
to the brand of conservatism he was
selling which is quite narrow very
right-wing so on that basis it's not
really ideological what it mostly is
there's a bunch of mps looking at each
other and thinking hang on
i mean let's forget the idea even for a
second that it's a matter of principle
if there was any principle about it they
would have taken action ages ago they're
looking at their own seats and going
hang on a minute i could actually be in
danger here and the only way i can
assess the extent of the danger to
myself in a general election is looking
at what happens in the local elections
so evidently those conversations are
happening and on a tactical level that
does seem to be a new development
very quickly both of you just want one
name from each of you because kate
raises the question about you know who
would would succeed him uh do you have
an amian
i think it'll be a backbencher anymore
maybe someone up anymore it could even
be tom tugan i mean it won't be that's
the big name that's the name just one
name and kate one from you
oh gosh i'm not in the habit of making
predictions but i'm not convinced morris
johnson's necessarily going anywhere not
in the immediate future
okay let's just um move on to this last
story in the metro um
and this is the story surrounding angela
rayna in what what do you make of this
story
well is it a story i don't know if you
can even call it a story
no it's a revelation of the absolute
jangled mess that is happening in
certain people's brains including
whichever tory mp decided to give this
story to the mail and the journalists
who wrote it up and those who authorized
it to go through it really i mean this
shouldn't even be a political debate it
is one of the most
genuinely grotesquely misogynistic
things i've seen in the british paper
for a very long time in which he is
essentially criticized for possessing
human legs as a woman but no it is
absolutely abysmal and all there is to
learn about it is just how broken
certain people in parliament and fleet
street truly are kate you've got about
10 seconds
well i agree with anne it's pretty great
test i suppose the lining of it all is
that in order to come out with these
horrible opinions you have to do it
anonymously now because everybody who's
gone on the record has condemned it even
the prime minister has weighed in in
angela raynor's favor and you know i
think that's silver lining from this
that you know huge public support is on
her side that you know this is not the
way that we talk about women in 2022.
indeed kate and ian thank you so much
see you in the next hour